piranha solution is a mixture of
hydrogen peroxide and concentrated
sulfuric acid it's thought they react
together to make some peroxy sulfuric
acid which is very good as oxidizing
organic compounds
a viewer was really keen to see what
would happen if we put an egg in piranha
solution because we'd already done the
chicken so we've answered the question
which came first the egg or the chicken
it's the chicken
so
i bought a selection of eggs and we
began putting an ordinary egg into the
piranha solution
now of course the shell of an egg
is largely calcium carbonate with not
much organic material so when we put in
an egg into piranha solution nothing
much happened it bubbled slightly and
the solution got really quite hot but
the egg itself remained intact
nothing's happened
and when neal broke it open
it was soft boiled
so this is a way of boiling an egg
but chemically it's not a very sound one
and i wouldn't eat the egg afterwards if
i were you
go on then
i discovered that our local supermarket
sells hard-boiled eggs without their
shell
and we put it in the piranha solution
which we'd already had the egg in so it
wasn't necessarily full strength but
what happened was that the outer layers
of the
white of the egg went brown and there
was more bubbling and interestingly the
egg rotated about once a minute or so
because bubbles built up underneath
and that was enough to turn the egg over
so gently turned round and round getting
a bit browner and still looking a bit
boring but then brady got really excited
at the idea of poaching an egg in
piranha solution
so with fresh piranha solution
neil cracked an egg
into the
piranha solution
and then
we got really quite a good reaction
this is definitely going to blow the top
first of all the egg white frothed up
with the oxygen
and it started to spill over
and then everything quietened down a bit
and then the reaction restarted with
quite an intense brown color which
almost certainly was the formation of
finely divided carbon that we've seen
before
by the end of the
reaction
there was none of the egg left
it may have been finely divided in the
solution but there wasn't anything that
you could pick out
so
as a way of poaching eggs it's totally
unsuccessful
now you may think these are really
rather stupid experiments
but they do demonstrate one really quite
important point about chemical reactions
and that is what is called mass
transport it's not enough for things to
be very reactive
but you have to get them together
mixed properly so that you can get the
reaction to occur with the ordinary egg
the piranha solution just cannot get
through the shell which is largely
calcium carbonate to attack what's
inside with a hard-boiled egg it can get
at the surface but the surface is quite
rigid so the mixing between the egg and
the piranha solution is very bad but
then
if you put in a raw egg which is largely
liquid apart from the yolk
then
you get good mixing between the piranha
solution
and the protein of the egg and bush it
takes off
so you've seen some nice pictures
and you've learned a good piece of
chemical engineering
maximize your mass transport if you want
to get a good reaction
and
really looked almost like an
advertisement for being a vegetarian
really yucky